honestly this season I've never thought
I had I've never gone like next week on
it it's always been like just like next
week one thing you know one next to the
next minute so they're like today that
like we need to freestyle song today I
was like huh I don't have it i don't i
was just worrying about bhangra like so
now that we're here it's amazing but
she's she's celebrating I'm like this is
like okay great celebrate now I'm gonna
like this am or yeah I'm kind of like
it's time to get into the rehearsal
studio right sorry ready to go let's go
we're in the finals holy cow no it's so
funny cuz all season long don't jinx if
we're talking about finals don't jinx it
now here's finals it's insane it's
insane I can't I can't I nobody could
have scripted this better I mean died
like nobody how would you imagine it
even the first day we're like all right
what is our expectation well yeah and we
have had fun yeah the entire time so now
that when the finals were gonna continue
that trend melissa has been my rock
she's been amazing to work with she's by
far the best student I've ever had and
on the floor she's my partner and that's
what we're gonna do we're gonna combine
our brains and try to come up with the
best freestyle possible and just
hopefully why would the audience once
more I know Wow work cited I don't even
know how this feels um well we'll let it
sink in a little bit but right now we're
so excited obviously the fans pulled
through for us
and keep voting keep watching I mean
this is why we're here who is your
support so it's awesome just in shock
very grateful very off off guard but
very precise very surprised me you
standing there against Emmett Emmett
Emmett Smith is I guess probably the
most biggest sweetheart of Dancing with
the Stars history the gentleman you know
on a show where it's predominantly
watched by women you know who would not
vote for him it so I guess another
voting for black Oh Kelly oh I'm very
grateful I'm so wet right now by the way
I apologize not my pants pants are wet
okay that doesn't help entertainment I
think honestly it's not about thinking
about winning are going into the studio
and being like we have to do something
good enough to win it's just about
living up to the standard that we've
kind of put out so far and each week
we've done you know we've made ourselves
proud and that's all you can do I think
I don't think anybody's really had too
much time to think about it but now that
you know what the competition looks like
you know you can make a plan of attack
at least because before whenever you
would even try to let your mind go there
you wouldn't know who the other people
were against you and so it's all girls
which i think is awesome awesome let the
girls beat the boys in this competition
it is me Kelly and Sean we're standing
on stage go on how did this happen but
it's so cool um and I think now going
into this week strategy is just thinking
what can we bring to the table that we
know nobody else can bring to the table
you know what can we show off that
nobody else can and I think that's the
approach probably that everybody's
taking and it at least gives us a
starting point on where to go um show
outages we go out have a great time to
celebrate the position that we r ya have
fun that's awful because you never know
what's happening out in the voting world
and that's one thing that I can honestly
say so for us it is the best person is
move for the best three have gone
forward and the public has spoken so at
the end of the day we we got to look at
ourselves say did we give it out and I
think we did and I think Cheryl has done
a great job in terms of getting me ready
for this competition and give me thus
far and not tried to do my part and
helping her get to that lip mirror ball
and so unfortunately fell this short
yeah I mean we pushed each other to the
max so we couldn't have done it any more
we couldn't have done any longer
rehearsals I couldn't push him any
harder so we did what we could do and it
was up to everybody else at home to vote
so Oh totally yeah we've been friends
throughout the six years of that gap and
we'll be friends forever I mean I'm so
close to his family and his kids and
this will be a forever have to come out
to San Francisco give a Smackdown
feeling dear friend I'm not putting
money on no human I've learned that a
long time ago but at the end of the day
we have three great contestants and I'm
looking forward to watching all three
and performance same I mean it's a
battle of all the women really i mean
it's it's crazy to see that so i think
it depends on on that freestyle whoever
brings the best freestyle will win the
competition at the end of the day we did
have an incredible journey and we have
grown so much closer together so much
stronger um but you don't want it to end
it's not I mean Mirrorball trophy
absolutely you know we both are
competitors that's what I grew up doing
that's what a bolo grew up doing so yeah
winning is in our blood but it's it's
the journey that I'm gonna miss it's
creating its watching him try the hip
action for the first time those are the
moments that Hogan is pretty much you
know it's it's it's those little moments
that make the whole journey that much
more special oh no no she never wants to
speak me and Stevie ever again no I I
hope so you know cuz you you go through
heart moments together you you'll see
each other your most vulnerable and I
think you learn a lot but you learn a
lot of our per person you learn a lot
about the person and the inner character
when they're pushed to the limit and how
do you react to that when you seemingly
feel like you can't do any more and I
think we both show that we have some of
the best qualities and that we don't
give up we don't quit and no matter what
the outcome will always continue
gosh darn it's coming up again my money
my money sunshine I don't have my knees